hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so let's get right
into this video here we're going to talk
about matrices I'm just going to go
through an introduction of matrices in
this video but I'm gonna have a whole
series about all different things that
you can do with matrices and we'll get
into that you can see the link at the
end of this video to see some of those
other videos but for this video we're
going to talk about the dimensions of a
matrix we're going to talk about what
the elements are in a matrix we're going
to talk about adding and subtracting
matrices and also scalar multiplication
so let's get right into it the first
thing we want to talk about is okay how
to identify a matrix well a matrix is
usually indicated with a capital letter
so you can see I've written ABCD these
are like four different types of four
different matrices here okay and you can
tell it's a matrix because of this
bracket see the little you know square
bracket there and each one of these
numbers here in the matrix is called an
element and you can identify the element
by its position for example these are
the rows that are going this way columns
are like the columns of a building and
when you want to name a matrix by you
know its dimensions
okay what you want to do is you always
want to do the rows first okay rows by
columns you want the columns to be
second okay so rows by columns forever
okay so the first row second row one two
three columns okay so this is a 2x3 okay
two rows three columns but if you wanted
to identify let's say this element right
here you would say it's in the second
row third column okay so you can see
like two three okay if you wanted this
one right here this is in the first row
first column okay so that's how you
identify the elements that's how you you
know name the matrix by its number of
rows and columns let's take a look at
this one here this one matrix B has one
two three now notice there's not much of
a row here there's just one element but
the rows go this way one
three and one column so this is going to
be a three by one this one here matrix C
one two rows one two three column so
this is a two by three and the last one
here this is actually called a square
matrix because it looks square right and
it's two rows two columns so the same
number of rows as columns two by two now
if you want to add or subtract matrices
they have to be the same dimensions they
have to be the same size it's like if I
pick up this matrix place it on this
matrix without rotating it okay just
translate it okay you can see that the
elements are not going to match up so
you can't add matrices if they have
different dimensions it's like a
dimensional mismatch so out of these
four examples it looks like matrix a and
matrix C have the same dimensions so
let's go ahead and add those two
matrices together so it's going to be
also a two rows three columns and what
we're going to do is just visualize
picking up this matrix placing it on
this matrix you're gonna add the
corresponding elements so three plus one
gives us four okay one plus 5 gives us
six two plus three is five zero plus
negative two is negative two negative
four plus zero is negative four and one
plus four is five so we added the two
matrices together now if you wanted to
subtract them it's the same thing you
would just do 3 minus 1 1 minus 5 2
minus 3 and so on okay so you can add
and subtract matrices as long as they're
the same size now what about a scalar
multiplication so scalar multiplication
is like multiplying everything in the
matrix by a constant so say for example
like let's take this matrix B okay so
matrix B let's write it out here 1 3
negative 2 say we want to triple
everything in that matrix so by writing
a 3 here in front of the matrix okay
it's just like the distributive property
are going to multiply that 3 into the
matrix and what do you get 3 9 negative
6
and that's it so I hope this gave you a
good introduction to two matrices rows
by columns adding and subtracting
matrices if you're enjoying these videos
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you in the future videos take a look at
the link for the next video in this
series on matrices and I'll see you in
that next video I'll talk to you soon